okay so in this quick video here we're
going to go over the basic differences
in a science experiment between the
independent variable versus the
dependent variable you know every year
when I do science experiments it seems
that I still have a number of students
who at the end of the school year are
kind of still mixing the two up so
hopefully this video will be a little
helpful here we go so when we go into
the independent and the dependent
variable we need to examine the two
major parts of a science experiment and
you might know that one part of an
experiment is called the control group
and the other part is called the
experimental group well what is so
special about the control group is
really nothing at all the control group
is the part of the experiment that
receives no special treatment and the
purpose of the control group is it's
going to give us some data and we're
going to use that data we're going to
compare that data to the other group
we're going to compare the data of the
control group to the data of the
experimental group so if the control
group receives no special treatment that
means whatever we're testing the
experimental group is going to receive
and so the experimental group is the
part of the experiment you set them up
exactly the same the experimental group
in the control group but the
experimental group is the part of the
experiment that receives whatever it is
you're testing and whatever it is that
you're testing is what we call the
independent variable it's the one factor
that's different from the control group
it's what you're testing let's see if we
can go over a simple example here we
have a picture of a young lady sleeping
let's pretend that she wanted to know
what effect does music have and the
ability to sleep through the night so
what we're going to do is we're going to
set up an experiment one group of test
subjects are going to listen to music
while they sleep one group of test
subjects are not let's go through that
right now
so when we set up a control group in an
experimental group you see that we keep
them exactly the same that means both
groups of test subjects whether it's
only one person or fifty people or a
hundred people let's say that we have
you know 50 people in the control group
and 50 people in the experimental group
what we're going to make sure that they
have a nice comfortable bed to sleep
upon both groups we're going to ask them
during the day both groups we're going
to ask them to do fairly similar at
physical fitness and you know try and
stay in good shape and practice good
health
both groups we're going to try to
balance out their diet have a
well-balanced meal carbohydrates
proteins lipids and we're going to try
notice how the two groups are exactly
the same so far and then the one thing
that's going to be different is okay the
experimental group receives the
experimental factor the in this case
whether or not they get to listen to
music while they're sleeping now please
note that this this example is fairly
simplistic yes there are other
experimental factors we would need to
set you know the age of the participants
the gender of the participants again
we're just kind of going over the broad
concept right here and so after the
experiment is finished let's say that
you record the amount of sleep that the
two groups of achieve for a month and
over the course of one month the control
group who did not get to listen to music
they slept continuously for about six
hours and then they woke up but then the
experimental group they slept
continuously for about eight hours and
so when we look at this this data here
is what we call the dependent variable
the data that you collect your results
the reason it's called the dependent
variable because the sleep depended on
the sleep the amount of sleep depended
on whether or not they had music the
dependent variable depends on the
independent variable and so that's why
it's called that and so anytime you're
measuring data in a science experiment
the data that you collect is your
dependent variable let's go over another
example of something
is this a good experiment again I
haven't changed any of the text but
watch the two of the pictures that show
up let's say again you're going to do
the sleep in the music experiment and so
again all the test subjects of the
control group get a nice comfortable bed
all the test subjects of the
experimental group get a nice
comfortable bed during the day however
you have them perform different
exercises during the day you have them
consume different kinds of food and then
when they sleep the experimental group
receives music the control group does
not receive music and let's look at the
data after one month pretend that just
like last time pretend that after one
month the control group on average slept
for about six hours before they awoke
and the experimental group slept for
about eight hours before they awoke I
hope you see a problem with this
experiment here this experiment the
results of this experiment would be
invalid this experiment has too many
independent variables there's too many
things that have changed between the
control and experimental group not only
have you changed the music you also
change the food that the people eat and
the activities they perform while
they're awake those also could cause
people to sleep longer perhaps the meal
the meals that you're eating are given
you are allowing you to have a better
night's sleep
maybe you're just more tired because the
exercise is more strenuous and that's
why you slept a total of eight hours
maybe you slept longer and music had
nothing to do with it so this is why a
good experiment only has one independent
variable
while you're go over a couple examples
watch this so here we have some army
soldiers and here's a little experiment
of fictional experiments here and it
says the United States military wants to
see if soldiers with only four hours of
sleep can operate at the same level as
those who normally get seven hours of
sleep 100 soldiers are allowed to sleep
for four hours a night and another 100
are allowed to sleep for seven hours a
night during the day that the soldiers
are tested for marksmanship on the
firing range well try to answer these
questions name the control group
experimental group independent variable
dependent variable pause the video pause
the video I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one alright so for
the control group these are the test
subjects that receive the normal and
it's normal to get about seven hours
sleep I think that's pretty normal even
in the military what's abnormal what's
different is the experimental group and
in this case what's different are those
who may only get four hours of sleep and
so when you look at the next part name
the independent variable the independent
variable is what's been changed what's
different between the two groups of test
subjects what's different between the
two groups of subjects is the amount of
sleep that they are given and then the
last one about naming the the dependent
variable remember the dependent variable
is the data that we collected how do we
know if sleep affected them what data
are we collecting in this case the data
we're collecting is the score on the
firing range can they hit the target
well can they hit the bull's eye so
here's another example
in this example here we have this farmer
right here and this farmer is going to
be testing his fertilizer mate so here's
a picture of the fertilizer that he
normally uses to grow his crops here's
my little story here farmer Bob wants to
test a new fertilizer to help his crops
grow better
he sections off two large areas of his
field in section a he waters his crops
as usual and uses his normal fertilizer
but in Section B he waters his crops as
usual and adds an experimental
fertilizer so after one growing season
he records the growth of the crops so
just like the last example with the Army
soldiers pause the video and try to
answer these four questions here pause
the video I'm going to go over the
answer in three two one
okay so identifying the control group
remember the control group is the normal
and in this case the normal section of
crops is Section A remember the
experimental group is something that
we've changed we've done something
different to the experimental group and
that would be section B of the farmers
crops and so name the independent
variable what's different between
section a and Section B there should
only be one thing different if you have
more than one thing different you have a
badly designed experiment but in this
case there's only one thing different
between section a and Section B and
that's the type of fertilizer that the
farmer uses he still he still waters the
crops as usual but he's using a
different fertilizer named the dependent
variable how does he know if his
traditional fertilizer is better how
does he know if the experimental
fertilizer is better he has to measure
something that's the dependent variable
he's measuring the growth of the crops
and allow one more example if in case
you're still not quite sure here's one
last example
here we have a young student and this
student wants to know if his new study
method is more successful than a
traditional study method he's been using
for years so for one month he studies
for his classes using his traditional
study method the next month he studies
for his classes using a new study method
and at the end of both of the study
parry periods of time he simply compares
his grades that he earned in school so
just like the last two examples pause
the video pause the video and try to
answer these four questions I'm going to
go over the answers in three two one so
I hope you see the control group would
be him studying with his usual his
traditional study methods because that's
that's what he's always done there's
nothing special there so for that one
month time when he was studying with his
traditional methods that's the control
group the experimental group is that one
month of one month period of time when
he used the experimental study method
again the experimental group is the
group that you've done something
different too and so in that second
month he was different because he was
using some new experimental study method
named the independent variable what's
different between those two months well
what's different is his study method was
he using traditional methods or
experimental methods and so that is what
the independent variable is it's the the
the difference between the two and in
this case it was how he was studying
named the dependent variable how does he
know what study methods better he has to
have some data the data that he has are
the grades that he's earned during one
month he earned grades while he studied
traditionally during one month he earned
grades while he studied with his
experimental method and he just compared
the two so the dependent variable is his
data his grades and that's it that's
that's the end of this video I hope it
was helpful if if you're in my biology
class and you still need some extra help
come on in and be happy to go over go
over this with you